bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
celui qui nous accompagne ce soir vous
le reconnaissez Emmanuel Valls bonsoir
et merci d'être notre grand témoin
ancien Premier ministre on va évidemment
revenir sur le drame d'Annecy le
président de la République s'est rendu
sur place mais on va aussi parler de
votre dernier livre chez Talandier le
courage guidait leur pas 12 destins face
à l'Histoire sur cette vertu mystérieuse
du courage dont on a eu un exemple
d'ailleurs à Annecy aujourd'hui avec cet
homme qui a permis de faire fuir la
saillant où on y reviendra longuement
dans la deuxième partie mais on commence
ce soir avec cette question nos
institutions sont-elles à bout de
souffle le débat électrique d'hier qui a
mis fin aux feuilles ton parlementaires
épiques sur les retraites relance la
question de notre régime politique
article 40 49-3 certains députés veulent
les supprimer certains ont même parlé
d'acte de décès de la Cinquième
République c'était hier dans l'hémicycle
alors notre Constitution est-elle
fatiguée faut-il la changer grand débat
dans un instant sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le programme on y va Manuel Valls
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
la crise des retraites c'est donc soldée
hier dans un hémicycle surchauffé la
réforme est donc promulguée mais à quel
prix il n'y aura pas eu de vote des 577
députés sur la mesure phare le report de
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans alors
crise démocratique pour les uns crise
institutionnelle pour les autres
certains opposants ont même parlé de
crise de régime alors ce débat
parlementaire chaotique plaide-t-il en
faveur d'une réforme de nos institutions
c'est la question qu'on se pose au
lendemain de cette journée agitée dans
l'hémicycle Christopher weisberg bonsoir
et merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des Français établis en
Amérique du Nord vous débattez ce soir
avec un Raquel Garrido bonsoir Merci à
VOUS député la France insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis vous pilotez au sein
de la nupesse un groupe de travail sur
les institutions bonsoir Pascal
Perrineau ravi de vous retrouver
politologue aussi professeur à Sciences
Po Paris enfin bonsoir Bastien François
ravi de vous accueillir dans cette
émission vous êtes professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université
parisien Panthéon Sorbonne
utile de préciser que Manuel Valls vous
pouvez intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez je suis sûr que vous avez une
idée sur la question de ce débat j'ai
mémoire que vous vouliez supprimer le
49-3 c'était lors d'une certaine
primaire en 2017 on en dira un mot mais
d'abord on plante le décor avec Stéphane
blackovski il a deux secondes le chrono
de Blacko c'est parti
alors on va se retourner pour vous
accueillir
Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors ce débat
institutionnel alors il y a un une
expression qu'on a beaucoup entendu ces
derniers mois c'est le déni de
démocratie ne serait-ce que hier
Bertrand planchaire quand on lui a dit
que ça pété elle était recevable déni
une démocratie la CGT quand les éboueurs
ont été réquisitionnés des lignes
démocratie Dominique Rousseau grand
constitutionnaliste par la déni de
démocratie pour la restauration même
Aurore berger parle de déni de
démocratie bon sauf que elle c'est pour
dire que ça n'existe pas et pourtant
quand on fait un sondage on en a fait un
7 semaines 64% des Français pensent que
la démocratie fonctionne mal dans notre
pays et c'est un chiffre qui a en hausse
de 10 points depuis 2021 vous voyez
c'est cette accélération là et peut-être
que la manière dont on a géré à la
réforme des retraites n'y est pas pour
rien cela dit si on prend un pro de
recul période par exemple je sais pas
quinquennat de François Hollande et je
ne vise personne on voit que le taux de
satisfaction d'un satisfaction plutôt
est encore plus élevé mais c'est
en même temps difficile de s'attacher à
un seul chiffre parce que l'opinion des
Français elle est très différente sur le
fonctionnement de la démocratie selon
qu'ils sont dans l'opposition ou plutôt
du côté du pouvoir en place regardez
vous voyez pour les électeurs d'Emmanuel
Macron bah il y en a seulement 25% qui
trouve que ça fonctionne mal alors que
pour ceux qui ont voté Mélenchon ou Le
Pen on est plutôt autour de 80 % et donc
c'est pas étonnant que à l'Assemblée ce
soit les députés insoumis qui soient les
plus véhément pour dénoncer le mauvais
fonctionnement de la démocratie on
écoute Antoine Léo man
la Cinquième République permet d'agir
sans le peuple et contre lui elle n'est
plus légitime en bas foi en ces
principes républicains vous accélérez sa
chute et la vôtre alors oui ah bah
Macron est la mauvaise République alors
attention on ne relance pas la polémie
bien sûr quand les insoumis disent ah
bah la mauvaise République qui
pardonnait la 5e parce que il y en a une
qui serait bien meilleure sont eux
Jean-Luc Mélenchon parle depuis
longtemps ça serait une sixième
république un vrai recommencement alors
cela dit du côté de la majorité on
aimerait bien aussi améliorer le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
d'ailleurs le président Macron l'avait
promis lors de son premier quinquennat
il voulait notamment plus de
proportionnelle moins de parlementaires
à faciliter l'accès au référendum sauf
que pour ça il faut s'entendre avec le
Sénat et comme Édouard Philippe avait dû
le constater c'était pas le bon moment
en 2019 cash lantienne président Macron
est réélu et il relance donc son projet
de réforme des institutions il a
rencontré ses prédécesseurs et il a
confié notamment il y a LeBron pipem
aussi à arracher le soin de faire des
réunions transpartisanes dans les
assemblées pour discuter de réforme des
institutions et Gaëlle elle est emballée
en écoute
moi je suis très allant extrêmement
lente sur la réforme institutionnelle
parce que le Président de la République
a souhaité organiser il nous a chargé
avec le président du Sénat de mener ses
consultations politiques dans nos
assemblées respectives et c'est ce que
nous allons faire très rapidement c'est
beau cet enthousiasme problème c'est que
ça risque d'être un peu plus compliqué
que ça puisque en sortant l'article 4 40
pardon de la Constitution contre la
fameuse PPL liotte elle fait fâcher avec
la nuit pêche qui décide de boycotter
ces fameuses réunions transpartizanes et
Olivier fan n'est vraiment pas content
l'écoute
vous n'irez plus aux réunions sur la
réforme des institutions
je ne vais pas continuer à faire le
guignol avec des gens qui me prennent
pour un con ah oui bah forcément alors
c'est peut-être pas le meilleur moment
évidemment pour lancer en ce moment une
réforme des institutions mais bon
rassurez-vous c'est jamais le bon moment
pour lancer une réforme des institutions
mais c'est toujours le bon moment pour
en débattre merci
beaucoup Stéphane j'ai commencé avec
vous Christopher Weissberg la charge des
opposants à la réforme des retraites et
aux 64 ans hier était extrêmement
lourdes je reprends quelques Verbatim
André Chassaigne la démocratie
parlementaire écrabouillée Charles de
Courson de cette abaissement ne peut
ressortir que des intérêts colères ou
pire violence est-ce que vous vous dites
bon c'est passé cette réforme mais cette
crise doit au moins être l'occasion de
relancer la réflexion sur les
institutions non mais bien sûr de toute
façon c'est pour ça qu'on est on est
tous les cinq en plateau et on y croit
tous avec chacun quelque chose qui va
pas bien sûr qu'il faut je pense changer
nos institutions et puis sur la méthode
c'est là je pense qu'il y a une grande
différence entre les oppositions cela
dit l'article 40 parce qu'il y a eu deux
épisodes il y a eu l'article 49-3 et
puis là je pense que on aura aussi notre
expérience monsieur le Premier ministre
sur ce qui s'est passé avant et pourquoi
pas le réformer ça a été déjà réformé il
y a une dizaine d'années pourquoi pas
encore le réformer l'article 40 de la
Constitution c'est un article que toutes
les démocraties parlementaires ont moi
je dans mes circonscription il y a le
Canada et les États-Unis qui interdit au
député de créer une charge financière
supplémentaire
il y a un article 40 les parlementaires
peuvent pas créer des charges de 16
milliards de d'euros ils peuvent pas
créer des charges en plus en Espagne
c'est pareil dans la plupart et même
dans la très grande majorité des
démocraties parlementaires c'est le cas
alors pensez aux institutions de manière
générale
alors que l'article 40 existe
les opposants ils disent que au fond les
macronistes n'ont pas pris conscience
encore un an après qu'il n'avait plus la
majorité absolue qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez bah moi je pense que en tout
cas c'est très clair que on a plus la
majorité absolue que contrairement il y
a 25 ans où il y a 30 ans quand Michel
Rocard était en majorité relative les
Français je pense aujourd'hui ont plus
de mal avec l'article 49-3 en tout cas
très clairement quand je vais sur les
plateaux je vois bien de la part de vos
collègues journalistes mais d'une
manière générale dans la population la
pratique du 49-3 est aujourd'hui moins
bien vécueil mais j'entends que vous
pourriez imaginer voir supprimer en tout
cas réfléchir à cette option Raquel on
va venir sur les propositions de fond
mais qu'est-ce que ça ça révèle ce qui
s'est passé cette séquence à l'Assemblée
vous vous avez carrément dit que la
séparation des pouvoirs n'était pas
n'était pas respectée oui au fond le
conflit des retraites a pris une
dimension nouvelle qui est la dimension
démocratique parce que la société
française qui était très magique
majoritairement hostile à la retraite à
64 ans à trouver à chercher des chemins
pour essayer que la volonté générale
émane d'elle alors il y a eu le moyen
syndical la grève la mobilisation la
présence et l'existence tout simplement
l'unité monolithique des organisations
syndicales ça n'a pas marché
la possibilité de voter dans l'hémicycle
ça n'a pas été possible à cause du 49-3
et on l'a vu hier aussi à cause d'autres
articles donc la difficulté quand vous
n'avez pas de chemin Pacifique comme
société pour faire la loi en quelque
sorte vous rentrez dans des autres
troubles et donc pour moi le procès en
quelque sorte de la ce qu'on a appelé la
monarchie présidentielle parce que le
problème au fond le confid des retraites
c'est un conflit entre un homme le
président de la République est un peuple
or et la constitution de 58 ne prévoit
pas une manière d'arbitrer ce conflit là
même il le nie puisqu'il dit il est élu
au suffrage universel donc le peuple
peut pas être contre le président et
donc
le réélire ou pas voilà donc du coup
j'ai l'intime conviction que le problème
il faut le situer correctement le
problème c'est le pouvoir du Président
de la République ce pouvoir qu'il a
d'abuser de son pouvoir et par
conséquent attendez il va falloir que la
Constitution ou ceux qui la font
fonctionner ben la Constitution parce
que je veux pas non plus qu'on se cache
derrière notre petit doigt c'est pas
seulement Emmanuel Macron je sais
qu'Emmanuel Macron provoque beaucoup
lire et l'irritation des gens mais
attention une autre un autre une autre
un autre individu doté d'autante pouvoir
et d'une minorité politique parce que je
rappelle que dans le cadre de la
tripartition de la vie politique
française en réalité les autres forces
politiques n'ont plus aujourd'hui n'ont
pas 50% comme on l'avait à l'époque
d'une dualité donc la question de savoir
comment on gouverne démocratiquement
dans cette configuration doit être posée
et ça ne peut pas être par une figure
autoritaire le président de la
République sorte de sauveur tout le
temps légitime qui aurait raison contre
tous et donc il faut partir de là et je
pense que la Sixième République qui doit
venir très rapidement parce que ça c'est
c'est Albert Camus qui disait lorsque la
démocratie est malade le fascisme vient
à son chevet mais c'est pas pour prendre
de ses nouvelles donc si on laisse les
choses en l'état c'est chaotique c'est
beligène et donc on sait pas ce qu'il en
a bien moi je suis pour le chemin
Pacifique ça doit commencer maintenant
voilà que le problème c'est le pouvoir
présidentiel tel qu'il est inscrit dans
la cinquième république Bastien François
déjà sur votre regard votre analyse sur
cette séquence qui s'est finalement
achevé hier ça va laisser des traces
ça va laisser des traces comme tout
laisse des traces depuis les dernières
législatives et ce qui s'est passé
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'on n'est pas de
majorité absolue et la façon dont de
pouvoir essayer de gérer assez
maladroits je crois
la façon dont il pilote puisqu'il en a
des instruments le programme législatif
mais je crois en réalité que on est dans
une crise qui est de beaucoup plus
longue durée qui vient de beaucoup plus
loin
et qui est lié je pourrais dire si je
voulais le dire très simplement qui est
lié quand même à des transformations
considérables de la société française
c'est-à-dire les formes d'exercices ou
de légitimité de l'autorité on
considérablement changé depuis 1958 les
rapports entre les parents leurs enfants
les rapports entre les hommes et les
femmes entre les profs et les élèves etc
la société qui ne supporte plus les
pouvoirs présidentielles tels qu'ils ont
été écrits en 58
ce que la société à mon avis ne supporte
plus c'est une façon une façon de
décider une façon de d'affirmer son
autorité
une une distance entre les représentants
et les représentés il faut bien voir en
1958 il y avait 180 000 étudiants
aujourd'hui on en a on a presque 4
millions ça fait français sont beaucoup
plus informés ils ont accès énormément
d'informations il y a des discussions
voilà il y a un espace public qui est
très très différent qui est très éclaté
mais en même temps beaucoup plus riche
donc on est dans un dans un dans un
espace public où les individus alors ils
sont d'ailleurs peut-être un petit peu
plus individualistes aussi attendre du
politique un autre rapport et par
exemple
j'enseigne le droit constitutionnel ça
n'a jamais posé problème le 49-3 ça a
commencé à poser problème avec Manuel
Valls ils s'en souvient sans doute et
moi qui disaient c'est mal c'est pas
démocratique je leur disais ben non 49-3
il a été justement
créé pour régler les problèmes que
Manuel Valls avait réglé c'est-à-dire
une fronde dans son propre camp voilà
donc je leur disais bah non c'est ça
Cinquième République et puis là on est
bon et c'est tout c'est intéressant
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est que des
choses qui étaient acceptées avant par
exemple lorsque Michel Rocard a été
premier ministre il y avait pas du tout
des des discussions infinies sur le 49
francs alors bien sûr c'est brutal le
49-3 ça a toujours été pensé comme une
arme brutale et une arme qu'on devait
utiliser que dans certains cas bon mais
aujourd'hui le 49-3 apparaît à taux ou à
raison mais enfin c'est c'est la rue qui
le dit c'est mes étudiants c'est bon etc
apparaît comme une façon pas normal de
fonctionner tout à l'heure c'est
exactement ce que disent les français il
va vous dire bah c'est mon cas il va
vous dire c'est dans la Constitution
voilà on applique la Constitution mais
la politique c'est pas on applique la
Constitution ça c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois que j'entends un
constitutionnalisme parler de la société
en général c'est les sociologues vous
vous dites il y a pas de crise
démocratique vous l'avez déjà dit ici
mais quand même si la société doit
évoluer peut-être que la pratique des
institutions aussi on n'est pas dans une
crise de régime voilà la démocratie en
effet les français s'interrogent sur son
fonctionnement on avait les chiffres
deux tiers des Français qui disent voilà
ça fonctionne mal voilà il faut en tirer
les conséquences est-ce que ça doit
passer par la énième dans la tradition
française
nouvelle Constitution la Sixième
République vous savez on a une maladie
franco-française c'est que dès qu'il y a
un problème on dit bah voilà faut
changer de régime le 19e le 20e en
France contrairement à la plupart des
démocraties c'est sans arrêt on change
de régime à la Libération la Quatrième
République dans les années 70 la
troisième un changement même continu
tout au début du du 19e siècle sur
empire
deuxième république oui ce serait
peut-être pas mal oui oui ça aurait
peut-être les regarde les américaines
avec le même type de régime qu'ils ont
fait évoluer donc je ne crois pas que la
réponse pour répondre à disait dans
l'assemblée soit la Sixième République
je crois que ça ne changera vraiment que
très peu les chats on va revenir et
qu'on en reviendra à de très vieilles
lunes qui ont fait la preuve que ça ne
marche pas qu'il n'y ait pas eu de vote
des 577 députés c'est pas un problème je
tiendrai ce raisonnement qui peut
apparaître comme paradoxal j'allais dire
heureusement qu'on a la constitution de
la 5e République pour gérer avec ses
armes du parlementarisme rationalisé
pour gérer la situation extrêmement
difficile tout à fait nouvelle que l'on
connaît avec la majorité relative c'est
eux qu'on a majorité mais la majorité
relative faible qu'a le le cas la
coalition aujourd'hui voilà et
heureusement et d'ailleurs le général de
Gaulle a créé avec Michel Debré ses
armes et d'autres d'ailleurs il y avait
des socialistes à l'époque dans le
comité consultatif ils ont créé ça
justement pour ce type de situation faut
pas croire la quatrième faut pas croire
vous allez en fait ah oui tout à fait
alors arrêt vous venez de dire qu'il
fallait pas de changer de compte parce
que c'était une maladie de
la cohérence est complète je me passe
pas là sur le terrain purement
constitutionnel je dis que lorsque en 58
des règles sont créées qui d'ailleurs
vont fait leur la preuve de leur
efficacité parce que ça sera cette
république qui aura duré le plus
longtemps maintenant et je crois qu'une
pérennité pour une constitution c'est
extrêmement important
c'est pas la première fois sur la
réforme des retraites je vous ferai
remarquer que quand vous prenez les
sondages jamais une majorité n'a été
favorable à une réforme de l'âge de la
retraite votre regard et ensuite on va
venir
ne se détermine pas dans les sondages
laissez-moi faire une phrase le
président minoritaire ici à l'hémicycle
donc si vous respectez les urnes jusqu'à
la majorité relative qu'est-ce que vous
dites les lois ne sont pas votées
madame Garrido s'il vous plaît ils ont
une allée plus importante que la vôtre
il y a plus de députés
à 64 ans ils auraient perdu c'est pour
ça qu'on n'a pas pu voter
je crois je parle sous la là
ce sont des urnes les
urnes nous ont mis ici dans une
situation de majorité par rapport les
urnes le président a fait campagne
s'il vous plaît madame Garrido vous avez
un ancien Premier ministre qui aimerait
bien s'exprimer et qui a une expérience
politique vous Premier ministre si vous
aviez été vous l'auriez utilisé ce 49.3
peut le faire j'ai dû l'utiliser sur
deux textes et donc autant de lecture
une première fois ce qu'au fond c'est la
pratique qui intéresse je ne suis pas en
situation donc on peut toujours imaginer
des scénarios la première fois à la
dernière minute sur un texte que
présentait le ministre de l'économie qui
s'appelait Emmanuel Macron puisque la
dernière minute ce qu'on appelait les
frondeurs ont annoncé que finalement ils
votait contre la question du travail du
du dimanche alors que tous les articles
avaient été débattus et voté et ensuite
sur la fameuse loi travail ou en effet
sans doute pour la première fois bah
tiens François a raison il y a eu un
basculement dans l'opinion mais je l'ai
utilisé c'est peut-être pour cela qu'il
avait été aussi imaginé parce qu'il y
avait une fronde parce qu'il y avait une
césure au sein de la majorité c'était
une différence par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé là parce que là il n'y a
qu'une majorité relative et alors que le
front syndical n'était pas unique comme
il l'est aujourd'hui puisque la loi
travail était soutenue par ce qu'on
appelle les syndicats réformistes
pour mes chefs notamment la CFDT j'avais
proposé quelques mois après non pas la
suppression du 49-3 lors de la primaire
socialiste mais en le limitant
uniquement au texte financier j'avais
dit très vite et je l'écris ensuite avec
un peu de recul et d'expérience que
parfois il se faut se méfier des
propositions qu'on essaie d'inventer
dans le cadre d'un débat vous trouvez
que le Parlement était malmené dans cet
épisode ou pas
il y a toujours ce sentiment que et le
Parlement et l'opinion puisque les
représentée par les députés par les
parlementaires peuvent être malmenés je
crois très juste là la remarque de de
Bastien François même si j'ai en tire
pas forcément les mêmes conclusions sur
le fait qu'évidemment les sociétés ont
évolué et qu'il y a même peut-être une
interrogation qui parfois m'inquiète sur
la démocratie mais pas seulement en
France un peu partout aux États-Unis
dans beaucoup de pays d'Europe avec des
systèmes politiques totalement
différents et il n'y a pratiquement
qu'en France je rejoins parce que le
périnot le fait que à ce moment là on en
tire la conclusion il faut changer les
institutions d'ailleurs créant dans le
pignon et en permanence le sentiment
que ces institutions ne fonctionnent pas
en tout cas on les affaiblit ainsi d'eau
moi je crois vraiment beaucoup mais
c'est là où il y a des désaccords et au
fond c'est un débat de bonne qualité que
la question qui est posée qui me paraît
majeur c'est la pratique des
institutions c'est à dire quand on a une
majorité relative l'esprit la pratique
de la majorité dans l'assemblée je l'ai
connu j'étais très jeune je travaillais
avec guitare Casson à ce moment-là au
cabinet du premier ministre qui
s'appelait Michel Rocard et nous
cherchions des majorités alternatives
soit avec les communistes à l'époque sur
le budget soit avec les centristes sur
d'autres sur d'autres sujets là le
problème c'est la pratique même du
président de la République depuis un an
qui n'a pas tiré de mon point de vue
toutes les conséquences sur le fait
qu'il avait une majorité relative et à
ce moment-là il faut chercher des
coalitions et même à gouverner en
coalition il pose évidemment d'autres
problèmes politiques mais je pense c'est
un défi de pratique politique de
rapports
et donc il faut faire très attention
parce que aujourd'hui on les fait le
pignon observe regarde justement les
Français examinent et donc et donc il
faut faire très attention on va les
écouter des situations beaucoup plus
tendues que celle que nous avons pu
connaître par le passé
par Emmanuel Macron de réfléchir aux
institutions pour l'assemblée le
président du Sénat de son côté elle
s'est lancée dans un tour de France des
citoyens quels sont leurs attentes et
bien camera embarqués avec elles ont un
monde un Gava aux Mureaux dans les
Yvelines regardez
bonjour à tous déjà je voudrais vous
remercier de vous être rendu disponible
pour ce temps d'échange on peut parler
du mode d'élection du président de la
République des députés de la durée du
mandat est-ce que il faut revenir à 7
ans est-ce qu'on reste à 5 ans est-ce
que par exemple on doit supprimer le
49-3 voilà moi je tous les sujets sont
ouverts donc voilà à vous monsieur je
pense que 49,3 c'est à peu près
l'équivalent de Lady royal de de il y a
300 ans et ça c'est inadmissible ne vous
étonnez pas que les gens n'aillent plus
voter qu'il n'est plus confiance parce
que nos politiques ont pris l'habitude
de nous trahir pour moi la base de
supprimer le 49-3 parce que à part
montrer à la population que peu importe
si elle se base si elle sort dans les
rues si elle montre son mécontentement
et ben ce que le président a décidé
c'est ce qui se fera donc pour moi c'est
la base c'est de supprimer 49 froid moi
je fais pas le lien entre la confiance
et le 49-3 mais peut-être que c'est une
erreur de ma part il faut qu'on dit 49-3
c'est un article de la Constitution
c'est un outil cet outil pendant le
Parlement peut mettre en jeu la
responsabilité du gouvernement en votant
une motion de censure le gouvernement
lorsqu'il enclenche le 49-3
il joue sa vie
allez-y monsieur donc j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi le vote électronique
n'a pas été mis en place pour que les
gens y voter il faut qu'ils se sentent
représentés une fois la fin de
l'élection et pour cela il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une dose de
proportionnelle sur la proportionnelle
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez dans la
salle la proportionnelle est quelque
chose dont on parle beaucoup et si je
vous demande de lever la main qui serait
pour sans parler de doses pas dose
nationale départementale mais juste sur
le principe la proportionnelle qui est
pour
peu importe
qui est contre
vous êtes un certain nombre vous êtes
abstenu
[Musique]
on n'a pas rédigé ce soir une nouvelle
constitution c'était pas l'objectif en
revanche on s'est dit des choses et ces
choses pour moi qui suis chargé non pas
de rédiger une nouvelle constitution
mais de travailler sur une évolution de
nos institutions et bien
pour y travailler j'ai besoin de savoir
ce que veulent les gens ça ne veut pas
dire que les citoyens sont
décisionnaires de tout tout le temps
mais les aliments que nos réflexions
donc c'est à ça que ça sert
François sur la méthode dans l'hypothèse
où voilà j'ai entendu Christopher
weisberg il veut ouvrir le chantier des
institutions on n'est pas dans la
Constituante de Jean-Luc Mélenchon là
c'est pas les citoyens qui l'écrivent de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de la France
insoumise pardon l'Assemblée
constituante c'est une idée historique
qui existe sur un format les Français la
République française a inventé ce format
absolument mais je m'adresse
cette démarche d'aller voir d'aller voir
les français puisque vous nous parliez
de la société c'est celle qu'il faut
mettre en avant aujourd'hui
tu observation avant de commencer la
constitution de la 5ème République c'est
à plus longue de l'histoire c'est aussi
la plus révisée il y a 27 révisions des
révisions extrêmement importantes la
dernière en 2008 plus d'un tiers de la
Constitution est intervisée donc il faut
peut-être pas avoir peur en réalité de
la difficulté la difficulté à laquelle
on fait face là c'est que il y a la
Constitution
il y a la pratique de la Constitution et
la pratique de la Constitution peut être
extrêmement loin du texte de la
Constitution par exemple l'article 20 de
la constitution d'une ville le
Gouvernement détermine est conduit la
politique de la nation tout le monde
sait que c'est pas le cas c'est le
président public bah oui mais donc c'est
un truc un peu bizarre on vit dans un
monde parallèle aussi dans la politique
par rapport à la Constitution et puis
trois il y a les représentations et ça
c'est très important
c'est le 49-3 là on a toute une série de
gens qui ont envie d'écouter qui nous
disent c'est mal c'est l'ancien régime
etc oui mais on peut pas faire comme si
ça n'existait pas bon donc si on veut
réformer les institutions vous voyez on
doit réformer quelque chose d'assez
compliqué à saisir c'est-à-dire
pas simplement le texte lui-même
juridiquement mais aussi des
représentations qui vont avec et en fait
en réalité une culture politique quelle
méthode alors s'il faut tenir compte des
représentations au 21e siècle si on veut
faire une méthode de révision
constitutionnelle adaptée au temps dans
lesquels nous sommes c'est une méthode
qui
la plus ouverte la plus inclusive
possible la plus
participatif et qui doit prendre du
temps parce que la discussion sur ces
sujets là est compliqué elle est
possible rappelez-vous le lire non pas
plusieurs années mais c'est pas en trois
mois et
regardez la discussion qui a eu en
France absolument incroyable sur le
référendum européen de 2005 et j'en
parle d'autant plus facilement que
j'étais très favorable au texte de la
Constitution européenne et que j'ai été
dans le camp des perdants et tout le
monde discutait de ça à se dire tout le
monde est capable de discuter plus ou
moins bien mais tout le monde est
capable et là vous imaginez qu'on dirait
au français
écoutez on va se donner je sais pas 9
mois pour discuter de la démocratie qui
nous intéresse qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
mettre dedans on sait faire on s'est
monté des dispositifs d'autres pays
l'ont fait il y a des expériences bon et
tout ça ça pourrait effectivement
aboutir à une forme de constituante dans
des formes constitutionnelles voilà
cette affaire viceberg je vous vois très
attentif
vous pourriez dire oui à cette à cette
méthode inclusive pour reprendre un
terme à la mode pour réfléchir avec le
pays à cette écriture d'une nouvelle
constitution évidemment j'ai envie de
dire que c'est d'ailleurs ce que fait il
y a le droit de Pivet dans dans le
reportage qu'on a vu la méthode
participative je pense que vous savez
bien que ça fait partie de l'ADN du
mouvement que je représente et donc oui
sur le principe après c'est difficile à
mettre en œuvre jusqu'à présent ça n'a
pas été un de ses chantiers il a fait ça
classiquement
politique c'est la grande différence
avec la France insoumise moi je crois
pas au Grand Soir institutionnel et
comme on dit je pense à peu près tous
les intervenants sauf peut-être vous je
crois que dans la pratique des
institutions on pourrait faire beaucoup
mieux il y a deux points moi sur les
règles électorales je pense par exemple
que si on mettait l'élection législative
le même jour que la présidentielle il y
aurait un intérêt en tant que député qui
serait très fort c'est que tout d'un
coup on aurait une très forte
participation des pour la Législative ce
qui n'est pas le cas puisque aujourd'hui
la l'élection maîtresse c'est quand même
la prise
de la dynamique présidentielle
exactement
mais justement parce que il faut penser
au fait que si on est plus au pouvoir et
puis président Macron sera plus au
pouvoir dans 5 ans il y aura une
alternative et moi je trouverai beaucoup
plus sain que on puisse voter en même
temps parce que ça relégit-il le
Parlement et le président serait face à
une composition qui devrait réinventer
par rapport aux résultats des
législatives alors que aujourd'hui il y
a un bonus majoritaire puisque
l'élection législative a lieu plus tard
ça c'est un point très concret qui je
pense changerait beaucoup nos
institutions et qui est beaucoup plus
facile à adopter qu'une réforme
constitutionnelle qui aujourd'hui quand
même paraît pratiquement impossible
je crois que une constituante même
préparée par un mouvement participatif
s'aboutira à une nouvelle constitution
je ne crois pas que la France a besoin
d'une nouvelle constitution c'est mon
opinion et que en revanche on peut faire
citoyen sur la constitution revanche on
peut faire évoluer la Constitution comme
on l'a fait à plus de 25 reprises par la
révision constitutionnelle c'est
d'ailleurs ce que propose je crois le
président de la République simplement il
faudra que les deux chambres se mettent
d'accord expliquer pour ceux qui nous
regardent et à moi en particulier
comment
comment justifier que le président ne
soit pas responsable du Parlement alors
que dans la pratique c'est lui qui
décide c'est lui qui gouverne est-ce que
c'est pas un problème écoutez nous avons
un régime qui est à part nous avons un
régime qui mêle à la fois des principes
de régime parlementaire puisque la
chambre si elle le veut si l'article 49
et 3 avait débouché sur une mise en
cause du gouvernement le gouvernement
était obligé de démissionner à du
président voilà et non pas le président
parce que nous avons laissez-moi aller
jusqu'au bout si vous le permettez nous
avons un régime mixte qui est un régime
qui mêle à la fois le régime
parlementaire avec la capacité du
président dissoudre du Parlement de
mettre en cause pour l'Assemblée
nationale de mettre en cause le
gouvernement et un régime qui est qui a
une partie présidentielle parce que le
président est élu au suffrage universel
direct et dispose de pouvoir que l'on
qualifie de pouvoir importante de
pouvoir propre donc c'est un mixte cette
constitution on sait très bien que la
Constituante que préconise la France ins
ça nous ramènerait un régime qui serait
régime
et même plutôt un régime d'assemblée à
mon avis
juste après la guerre c'est plutôt le
régime d'assemblée même que le régime
parlementaire que cette tradition s'est
traditions proposent je crois que quand
on regarde l'histoire constitutionnelle
du pays le mélange de ces principes qu'a
réussi la Cinquième République est
plutôt un plus qu'un moins alors il ne
reste très peu de temps Raquel Garrido
et puis on terminera avec manuels et sa
dimension maintenant institutionnelle a
pris corps dans la société c'est à dire
que le débat existe à l'échelle
intellectuelle théorique etc mais
surtout il existe dans la société comme
vous l'avez très bien montré dans ce
reportage et ça c'est une chance parce
que soit on peut dire que le peuple ne
croit plus à la démocratie elle-même en
parlant en prenant appui par exemple sur
l'exemple américain ou autre et on se
dit bon bah de toute façon bah alors
passons-nous de la démocratie il y a
aussi dans certaines élites l'idée un
peu poplophone que bon bah finalement
c'est pas grave ils veulent plus de la
démocratie ok on endra plus moi je pense
que les Français sont majoritairement
attachés à la démocratie l'aspiration
démocratique est profonde et majoritaire
pour le moment et qui donc il faut
prendre appui là-dessus pour faire ce
que dit Bastien François c'est à dire
entrer dans un processus de délibération
qui doit sécréter une constitution qui
ressemble aux Français voilà un mot pour
terminer ce débat on n'a pas parlé de
l'association du citoyen à la décision
ça c'est quelque chose qui est quand
même très très demandé on le sent à
travers différents mouvements la société
française a évolué depuis 1958 la
Constitution d'ailleurs a évolué
notamment en 1962 c'était la réélection
du froid au suffrage universel du
président de la République mais j'ai la
conviction que le génie parce qu'il y
avait un génie du général de Gaulle
c'est d'avoir compris ce dont ce peuple
ce pays avec son histoire avec ses
radicalités avaient besoin comme type
d'institutions ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir des remises en cause
c'est normal nous sommes dans une
démocratie moi j'ai prouvé dans des
circonstances particulières il est vrai
face au terrorisme la solidité de nos
institutions et et on le voit aussi
maintenant alors cette solidité des
institutions qui nous permet de
gouverner dans la durée contrairement à
ce qui s'est passé sous la Quatrième
République ça doit être examiné moi
j'étais un premier ministre pardon qui
qui avait tous les pouvoirs qui étaient
les sièges les ai exercés dans un
rapport de confiance avec le président
de la République donc le respect donc
c'est une question de personnalité le
respect des corps intermédiaires comme
on dit sert des élus locaux ou des
partenaires sociaux le respect de la
majorité mais aussi du Parlement le
respect de la personnalité de son
premier ministre qui doit qui doit aussi
s'appuyer dans un rapport fort avec le
législatif tout cela renvoie ce que je
disais sur la pratique c'est on peut
toujours améliorer les institutions bien
évidemment qu'en faut-il trouver un
accord avec le Sénat et puis je suis
convaincu que les Français ne veulent
pas être dépossédés de l'élection au
suffrage universel du président et que
le président brut doit avoir des
pouvoirs importants
on va s'arrêter là Raquel Garrido je
pense que le débat est terminé je le
président aujourd'hui c'est le côté
monarchique quand on vous parle de
danser un régime
c'est la question du contrôle mais en
revanche le pouvoir du président
la couleur responsable mais mais en tout
cas ça peut pas durer comme maintenant
c'est clair de la personne qui consomme
tous les pouvoirs gouvernants et qui
n'est responsables devant strictement
on va s'arrêter là merci infiniment
c'est un débat qui va se poursuivre je
vous propose de revenir quand vous
voulez sur la Chaîne Parlementaire parce
que c'était passionnant vous restez avec
moi Manuel Valls dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir le mot de la semaine
de la sémiologue Mariette darrigan c'est
le mot français que les politiques
mettent à toutes les sauces et puis
l'avocat Bertrand Perrier va pousser un
petit coup de gueule contrôle Sénat qui
vient d'autoriser l'activation à
distance des caméras des téléphones dans
certaines enquêtes et puis d'un Bourbon
Express Elsa ce soir je vous fais
compter je vous fais compter jusqu'à 17
comme le nombre de motions de censure
depuis un an ici à l'Assemblée Elsa
m'ont d'un Gava merci à vous les
affranchis à tout à l'heure on revient
avec vous Manuel Valls à la fois sur
votre livre mais aussi sur le drame
d'Annecy parce qu'il est évident qu'on
entend qu'on a envie de vous entendre et
et la réaction d'un ancien Premier
ministre qu'on regardait c'est dans
l'invitation de Marion Becker
si on vous invite Manuel Valls c'est
pour votre regard sur la situation peut
traverser la France celui d'un ex
Premier ministre et d'un spectateur
engagé comme vous vous définissez
vous-même désormais il y a quelques mois
Manuel Valls vous sortiez de votre
silence médiatique et vous publiez un
livre sur le courage une galerie de 12
portraits et des personnalités dont le
courage à guider les pas Jean Moulin
évidemment
[Musique]
courage de cet homme
vous saluez aussi le courage de ces
hommes d'État Clémenceau le tigre devenu
père de la victoire Churchill qui disait
lui-même que c'est la première des
qualités humaines parce que c'est celle
qui garantit toutes les autres
le courage également de charme et
directeur de Charlie Hebdo les 343
femmes qui dans Le Nouvel Observateur
s'engageaient pour l'IVG mais aussi la
figure révolutionnaire de Louise Michel
le courage un héritage qui devrait selon
vous guider l'action publique et la
politique dans laquelle manuel vase vous
êtes tombé très jeune engagé aux parties
socialistes à peine naturaliser français
dans les années 80 vous soutenez Michel
Rocard puis deviendrait conseiller en
communication de Lionel Jospin mère
d'Evry pendant 11 ans puis député vous
devenez ministre de l'Intérieur de
François Hollande puis son premier
ministre
le 13 novembre 2015 vous êtes au cœur du
pouvoir lorsque la France est secouée
par une vague d'attentats terroristes
Charlie Hebdo hypercacher le Bataclan
Nice
hier la nation a été plongée dans
l'effroi après une attaque au couteau à
Annecy quatre enfants en bas âge et deux
adultes ont été blessés par un homme
isolé un réfugié syrien d'origine
chrétienne aucun mobile terroriste n'a
été retenu le procès en laxisme ne tient
pas à leur manuel Valls comment réagir
face à l'inexplicable
votre réaction sur Annecy Emmanuel Valls
par la dignité et par la responsabilité
d'abord en pensant évidemment aux
victimes et puis à ces personnes
notamment à ses gamins ces bébés qui
luttent encore pour pour leur survie et
puis en faisant en sorte que sur ces
questions là si c'était possible je ne
suis pas là il faut savais chez
l'expérience mais que l'unité nationale
soit un élément fondamental face à la
violence quel que soit on n'est pas du
tout on avait vu ces tweets
l'immigration à contrôler tu ça c'est ce
qu'a tweet Marleix elle est demandeur
d'asile qui désormais leur pays pour
tuer nos enfants c'est Éric Zemmour en
parlant de Franck aussi ils ont parlé
trop vite sans attendre il y a une
course au tweet une forme d'indignité
dans les dans les réactions dans la
récupération sans doute on va trop vite
et donc il faut il faut être capable
parce que nos démocraties nous voulons
d'en parler sont sensibles sont fragiles
parce que l'actualité c'est aussi une
question qui est posée pour vous
journaliste
emporte tout et face à des actes
terribles vous savez dans les scénarios
possibles qu'on examinait qu'on le
gouvernions après les actes terroristes
il y en avait un terrible quand j'en
parle je parle toujours avec émotion qui
était l'attaque d'une d'une école il y a
déjà eu on oublie très souvent une école
attaquée Toulouse à Toulouse c'était une
école on l'a tué des gamins donc la peur
d'un attentat de masse dans dans une
école a toujours été présente parce que
là on voit bien que l'opinion peut
basculer on touche d'une certaine
manière ce qu'il y a de plus sacré c'est
à dire des enfants donc oui la dignité
et la responsabilité il n'y a pas
d'autre chemin si nous voulons être fort
face aux terrorisme face à la violence
face au basculement que nous avons connu
26 qui ne veut pas dire que nous n'ayons
pas un débat je l'ai dit on sera là je
sais que c'est impossible mais sur les
questions d'immigration mais chaque
chose en son temps avec méthode parce
que pour traiter les questions
d'immigration et moi je pense qu'il faut
radicalement changé dans ce domaine là
le politique
il faut du temps parce que il faut
trouver des consensus il faut des
politiques de long terme pour bien
expulser et il le faut pour réformer le
droit d'asile pour mener une autre
politique en Méditerranée et en Afrique
pour remettre en cause si c'est
nécessaire je le crois nécessaire
l'accord de 1968 avec l'Algérie comme le
propose l'ancien l'ambassadeur des
encours ou Édouard Philippe c'est les
politiques qui nécessitent de trouver
des consensus larges au Parlement ce
sont eux aussi des actions de moyens et
de et de long terme il faut retrouver
cette responsabilité sinon nous allons
être emportés en permanence par
l'émotion et par l'opportunisme
politique dans la barbarie de cet acte
je rappelle qu'il y a pas de mobile
terroriste et que le procès relaxant ne
fonctionne pas ça n'était pas un
islamiste c'est un chrétien d'Orient et
manifestement les enquêtes
psychiatriques le diront il y avait un
problème de ce point de vue il y a aussi
des héros dans ces moments-là Henri que
l'on a surnommé l'homme au sac à dos qui
a poursuivi la seyant la saillant qu'il
a fait fuir et puis bien sûr les
policiers on va écouter le président de
la République qui salue leur courage
ils sont intervenus avec beaucoup de
courage pour s'interposer sans se poser
de questions et qui
dans une actualité qui parfois nous fait
voir le pire des visages de l'humanité
nous disent au combien
avoir reçu une éducation portée des
valeurs et savoir trouver en soi les
ressorts de ce qui nous tient debout et
les plus belles valeurs permet de faire
des grands gestes
voilà des grands gestes le courage au
nom des valeurs qu'elle est cette vertu
du courage que vous auscultez dans votre
livre et qui et qui se révèle ou pas
d'ailleurs chez chacun d'entre nous
dépend d'un moment d'un événement le lit
sans doute le plus difficile à faire et
pas celui que j'ai écrit sur des grandes
personnalités qui sont des références
qui nous dépassent par le poids qui est
le leur dans l'histoire mais c'est le
courage parfois des anonymes du policier
qui est rentré dans le dans le Bataclan
et qui a tué l'un des terroristes
sauvant sans doute des dizaines de vie
ce sont les gens qui sont intervenus
l'autre jour à Annecy oui il y a ce sont
les justes pendant l'occupation qui ont
sauvé sans se considérer comme des héros
des des enfants ou des familles des
Juifs c'est le colonel Beltrame
évidemment qui a pris la place d'un
otage lors là d'une opération terroriste
c'est un moment donné où tout bascule
vous savez il y a une personnalité que
je cite même si j'avais déjà eu
l'occasion de faire un portrait qui est
Geneviève De Gaulle Antonio la nièce
générale de Gaulle qui qui est rentré en
résistance le 17 juin 1940 la veille du
discours de son oncle mais en écoutant
le message de soumission du Maréchal
Pétain c'est comme un instinct d'une
certaine manière c'est comme c'est comme
l'amour et donc voilà il y a quelque
chose qui bascule au nom de valeur
parfois d'une expérience et parce que
c'est une haute valeur morale alors dans
votre panthéon de ces 12 destins face à
l'histoire on retrouve vos héros de
longue date Clémenceau Camus Jean Moulin
aussi vous parler du préfet d'ailleurs
très intéressant les angles que vous
choisissez c'est pas des angles
classiques c'est très original
à chaque fois vous prenez voilà le temps
de revenir sur un parcours mais aussi
d'expliquer ce qu'il a changé pour vous
et et de raconter des des parties de
l'histoire peu connue alors moi j'en ai
retenu quelques-uns Louise Michel ça m'a
surpris de voir Louise Michel la
révolutionnaire l'anarchiste pourquoi
vous fassiez une telle vous ne partagez
pas vraiment ces idées non mais parce
que je suis arrivé à Louise Michel grâce
à Georges Clémenceau et à l'amitié qu'il
est qu'il est lié voilà deux personnages
totalement différents mais qui se
rencontrent à Montmartre lui il est le
maire de Montmartre pendant la guerre de
70 pendant la Commune elle est
institutrice et c'est là où il commence
à se à se connaître ils sont différents
Clémenceau voit très vite d'ailleurs
comme Victor Hugo les limites de la
commune les exactions qui sont
insupportables Louise Michel et radical
mais elle est fascinante parce qu'au nom
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes devant ses juges elle réclament
la peine de mort qu'on implique aux
hommes et pas aux femmes elle sera
ensuite déportée en Nouvelle-Calédonie
mais n'acceptera pas une admistie
partiel que propose Clémenceau et elle
sera institutrice qu'elle
1980 au moment d'une amnistie il y a
plein de filles comme ça
notamment la Nouvelle-Calédonie parce
que ça c'est important pour vous
le couple mendelstam je voulais
m'arrêter sur eux je les ai découvert
nadègeda et aussi Mandel Stan qui
était-il aussi est un immense poète
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui qui était pas
non gagé politique même si il avait il
avait suivi la révolution bolchévique je
crois qu'il était aux obsèques de de
Lénine mais ça c'est un poète pur c'est
c'est une âme pure qui écrit sur la
nature sur l'amour sur les paysages sur
la Russie et qui tout à coup écrit un
poème contre Staline dont il supporte
pas évidemment les crimes se pointe
personne ne lit sauf des proches comme
grand écrivain Boris pasterna qui était
effrayé par le seul fait de l'avoir lui
il pourrait complice de cette critique
de Staline il sera condamné parce que
dénoncé déportés il bras il mourra
il y a la pureté de la poésie c'était
pas uniquement courageuse c'est pas
uniquement un acte d'un politique
sa femme apprend par cœur tous les
poèmes pour les sauver après
et qu'on peut lire et publier que c'est
magnifique il y a une édition notamment
en français et en russe elle mourra bien
plus tard et elle sauve son œuvre ça
c'est un acte de courage sauvé une
oeuvre c'est comme quand Clémenceau
surveillaient gardaient les tableaux de
son ami monnaie les impressionnistes
parce que certains voulaient les
détruire la culture doit être protégée
donc il y a des courageux qui la
protègent comme cette femme le seul
contemporain de dans ces 12 destins dans
ces dans ces 12 personnes passages
personnalité c'est volodinir Zelenski il
faut quand même dire un mot de lui parce
que vous dites au fond que certes il y a
ce courage inouï mais il y a aussi tous
ces codes politiques qu'il a fait
exploser oui alors c'est toujours
difficile de prendre contemporain parce
qu'on ne sait pas comment l'histoire va
se terminer mais il y a quelque chose
comme Bernard Henri Lévy a pu l'écrire
de churchillien de gollien chez lui il
refuse d'être
extradé enfin de d'être exfiltré plutôt
par les Américains au moment de
l'invasion russe dans un coffre de
voiture et c'est lui grâce à son
portable au FaceTime qu'il filme en
montrant qu'il n'a pas fui Kiev puisque
la propagande russe explique qu'il est
parti non on voit Kiev derrière et par
la manière de s'habiller la manière de
s'exprimer cet homme a parlé devant tous
les assemblées du monde et pas seulement
les assemblées parlementaires mais aussi
le Festival de Cannes Davos etc il
introduit la communication comme un
élément de la résistance et ces mots
comme le discours de Churchill devant la
Chambre des communes comme l'appelle du
général de Gaulle en 1940 à électriser à
donner la force au peuple ukrainien pour
défendre leur démocratie mais ils nous
défendent aussi ce sont les courageux
nos valeurs la démocratie et l'Europe
politique savons ou pas vous avez connu
des hauts des bas
ça vous manque plus si ça manque bien
évidemment c'est l'action qui manque
mais moi je ne vis pas avec
le regret encore moins la rancoeur sinon
c'est dramatique donc j'observe je suis
en effet un spectateur engagé j'écris
nous avons toujours il y a toujours
c'est le code on prend les destins de
Clémenceau de Churchill et de Gaulle aux
se dit toujours on peut revenir
il faut laisser faire les choses j'ai eu
la chance d'avoir les plus grandes
responsabilités faut se laisser porter
aussi par la vie c'est ça
qu'il faut être libre on peut pas avoir
toutes les contraintes je me sens très
libre de m'exprimer de dire ce que ce
que je pense mais toujours avec l'amour
de mon pays parce que je suis morte
elle a commis que des erreurs selon vous
il y a toujours un besoin de gauche dans
ce pays d'égalité de fraternité
d'espérance de justice sociale bien
évidemment mais vous savez je m'étais
exprimé déjà par le passé sur tel qu'il
y avait des gauchers réconciliables leur
vision du monde de l'Europe de la
République de la société sont aux
antipodes on peut pas uniquement être
contre donc seul moyen un jour de la
gauche de se faire entendre c'est
d'avoir un message positif mais elle vit
une très profonde crise d'idées et
institutionnelle et c'est pour ça
qu'elle est vraiment pour ne pas prendre
trop de temps sur les chroniques qui
arrivent le macronisme à votre avis il
suivrait survivra à Emmanuel Macron je
ne sais pas non parce que je pense que
cette manière non parce que je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas voulu bâtir
un parti et une doctrine qui lui
permette de durer mais attention il lui
reste quatre ans c'est beaucoup et le
pays a besoin de réforme mais aussi a
besoin d'apaisement de réconciliation
avec lui-même Manuel Valls le courage
guidait le repas 12 destin face à
l'Histoire merci beaucoup c'est à lire
chez Tallandier vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure des partis pris de nos
affranchis on les accueille tout de
suite ils vont vous faire réagir
allez on y va mettre Bertrand Perrier
qui nous parle d'une décision du Sénat
qu'il a un peu fâché cette semaine
Mariette darrigran et son mot de la
semaine les Français à toutes les sauces
dans la bouche des politiques mais on
commence comme chaque soir par le
bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est raconté ce soir par
elsament d'un Gava bonsoir Elsa bonsoir
je vous raconte l'histoire de la 17e
motion de censure que va devoir
affronter Elisabeth borne ce sera en
début de semaine dans l'hémie cycle une
motion de censure annoncée des hier par
les représentants des quatre groupes de
laupes
membre de l'Inter groupe nupes nous
avons aujourd'hui fait un serment
serment de ne jamais lâcher le combat
contre la retraite à 64 ans et de
continuer sur notre objectif commun du
droit à la retraite à 60 ans l'ensemble
des groupes de laupes porteront une
motion de censure qui devrait être
examinée je pense au début de la semaine
prochaine il nous semble important que
nous marquions le fait que nous
n'accepte pas que la démocratie
parlementaire et la démocratie dans son
ensemble ça au bafoué de cette façon
comme à son habitude le rassemblement
national à d'ores et déjà dit qu'il
votera cette motion
lorsque le gouvernement et une majorité
se permet d'attenter à ce point au
fonctionnement démocratique d'un pays
il mérite la censure c'est en tout cas
ce que je plaiderais devant mes députés
en revanche le groupe liote ne signera
pas cette motion pour le vote ce sera à
chaque infest qui lui plaît le
porte-parole du groupe Benjamin saint
tuile nous explique pourquoi
moi je considère que ce gouvernement
doit partir qu'il est allé au bout de
son processus et qu'il a démontré son
incapacité est-ce que ça doit passer par
l'utilisation du motion de censure je
suis pas sûr si jamais il n'était pas
censuré ils auront l'outrecuidance de
nous faire croire qu'ils sont légitimes
bon alors pourquoi elle a aucune chance
d'être adoptée cette motion de censure
non ça il y a pas de suspense elle a
aucune chance d'être adopté la vraie
question c'est de savoir est-ce qu'elle
va faire plus ou moins de voix que la
dernière fois je vous le rappelle
c'était le 20 mars dernier après le 49-3
la motion transpartisane portée par
l'inénarrable short de Charles de
Cousson de liotte elle avait échoué à
neuf fois près je pense que quand on est
premier ou première ministre garder sa
place à neuf fois près c'est un sacré
avertissement le résultat avait été plus
serré que prévu à l'époque liotte avait
voté ainsi que la gauche et le
rassemblement national mais la surprise
avait été les 19 députés de droite du
groupe donc les républicains qui avaient
voté pour cette motion sauf que cette
fois-ci il devait être beaucoup beaucoup
moins nombreux donc elle peut souffler
au moins là dessus Elisabeth exactement
à priori un gouvernement d'Elisabeth
borne ne tombera pas la semaine
prochaine ça lui donne un peu plus
d'espérance de vie mais survivre à une
motion de censure c'est pas non plus un
totem d'immunité ça fera patère les
rumeurs de remaniement elle commence à
faire beaucoup de bruit ces rumeurs
merci beaucoup Elsa Bertrand vous dit
revenir sur une décision assez
controversée qu'on prise les sénateurs
la semaine prochaine la semaine dernière
ils ont permis dans le cas de la réforme
justice d'activer à distance nos
appareils téléphoniques de quoi
parle-t-on précisément oui c'est une
chronique Big Brother ce soir Myriam
puisque en effet mercredi le Sénat a
voté une disposition qui permet aux
enquêteurs policiers et gendarmes et
bien d'activer à distance vos appareils
électroniques chez vous d'allumer la
caméra d'allumer les micros pour vous
filmer évidemment à votre insu et sans
votre consentement ou enregistrer ce qui
se dit dans votre appartement alors
l'idée peut-être soit de vous localiser
ou de localiser votre téléphone portable
soit donc de vous filmer ou de vos
enregistrer à votre insu alors c'est
pour faire une sorte de suivi et
s'adapter à l'évolution des technologies
dans le cadre de certaines enquêtes oui
alors évidemment la délinquance
elle-même progresse y compris dans les
moules moyens techniques et
Eric Dupond-Moretti explique que en
réalité c'est très compliqué aujourd'hui
parce que pour enregistrer les images ou
les sons il faut aller poser des micros
des balises que c'est pas toujours
possible que c'est du temps et que c'est
parfois complexe et quoi qu'il est plus
facile de passer directement par
l'ordinateur ou le téléphone des gens
évidemment c'est décidé par un magistrat
encore heureux c'est limité dans le
temps encore heureux et ça peut pas être
sur certaines professions avocats aux
journalistes encore heureux
commentaires hurle les associations oui
c'est pas absolument sans raison
évidemment tout le monde sait qu'il faut
lutter contre la criminalité organisée
les formes de délinquance de plus en
plus sophistiquées bien sûr mais tout de
même il y a une atteinte forte à la vie
privée on a un peu passé un cap d'abord
l'activation éloignée de ces dispositifs
électroniques et simplement subordonnée
à une qualification juridique c'est
assez évanescent il suffit de dire
j'enquête sur un blanchiment au bon
organisé une escroquerie en bande
organisée et je peux déclencher ces
mécanismes sans que la qualification
soit vraiment contrôlée et puis les
personnes de qui on peut écouter le
téléphone portable ou filmer une
personne soupçonnée mais c'est quoi une
personne soupçonnée et puis sa famille
et puis ses proches et puis son
entourage et puis il y a des gens qui
sont écoutés par ricochet vous allez
chez quelqu'un vous savez pas qu'il est
écouté mais vous êtes écouté par
ricochet vous êtes filmé par ricochet
vous croisez quelqu'un dans la rue qui
est sous écoute vous êtes écoutez par
ricochet et vous ne le savez même pas
donc la pente est glissante bien sûr
qu'il y a la garantie du juge mais c'est
toujours pareil ça rentre dans les
habitudes les enquêteurs vont expliquer
que c'est très important qu'il puisse le
faire et peut-être que les juges vont se
laisser aller et je crois que ces
dispositifs pourraient se banaliser et
c'est dangereux dans les années 70
Michel Foucault a publié surveiller et
punir je voudrais juste qu'on fasse
attention à ne pas trop surveiller sous
prétexte de mieux punir merci en voilà
un parti pris et un avertissement merci
Bertrand vous étiez ministre de
l'Intérieur quel est votre réaction
attention aux dérives j'ai surtout porté
la comme premier ministre d'ailleurs la
grande loi sur le renseignement qu'il y
a intégré les nouvelles technologies de
la communication
honnêtement je connais pas le texte je
connais pas ses dispositions mais
d'abord il faut s'adapter à ces
nouvelles technologies en permanence le
plaidoyer était brillant
mais s'il y a le juge derrière en tout
cas celui qui surveille cette
application c'est quand même de mon
point de vue déjà une manière de le
rassurer mais il faut faire évidemment
très attention au fond moins à ce que
fait un état dans une démocratie
contrôlée comme la nôtre que ce que peut
faire
les gens du numérique c'est ça moi qui
me préoccupe bien davantage que l'action
contre la délinquance ou la criminalité
qui doit être toujours je le répète
encadré mais il faut aussi donner les
moyens à la justice et en même temps
Mariette les Français partis les
Français par là on les a beaucoup
entendus dans la bouche des politiques
cette semaine c'est votre mot pourquoi
c'est une expression dire on a entendu
tout à l'heure dans le débat Myriam mais
je vous ai préparé un petit florilège
sur la longue séquence des retraites
Jordan Bardella les Français n'ont pas
vocation à travailler jusqu'au cimetière
Mathilde panot les Français iront
jusqu'au bout Bernard lacher il faut de
la proximité avec les Français Elisabeth
borne nous
nous nous avons fait ce que les Français
attendaient de nous mais qui sont ces
Français que tout le monde s'attribue
vous pensez que en réalité on ne les
connaît pas oui je pense que c'est une
façon de ne pas les connaître alors
évidemment pas chaque personne mais
globalement parce que cette ce
métaconcept en fait leur font faire des
erreurs aux politiques alors je vais en
prendre deux cette semaine Carole Delga
la reconnu elle-même que c'était une
bourde de parler de l'immigration
réussie incarnée par Mbappe et Noa mais
je crois que c'est à mettre en rapport
avec ce qu'elle avait dit auparavant
dans l'entretien les Français ont besoin
d'espoir voilà toujours cette même
formule alors ces Français générique
sans vie français de papier et il faut
bien voir que les politiques ont
emprunté la formule au sondeur mais
autant c'est justifié quand un
statisticien a compté ces grandes masses
etc autant dans la bouche du politique
c'est beaucoup moins justifié donc je
vais prendre l'exemple cette fois à
droite de Edouard Philippe il a repris
la parole fortement avec les Français
trouvent à 74% qu'il y a trop
d'étrangers en France c'était avant
c'était avant an et je crois que bon
évidemment ça peut faire une émergence
politique on peut prendre
spectaculairement la parole mais on est
dans ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
marketing politique un peu grossier un
peu basique un peu macro c'est ça qui
vous gêne manifestement alors le
marketing politique en soi ne me gêne
pas mais quand on fait du marketing il
faut en faire du bon et le bon marketing
il est pas mainstream il est toujours
l'art d'aller trouver des signaux
faibles donc je vais en donner deux
pour Carole Delga bon il était litiste
mon signal faible je le reconnais mais
les bobos des grandes villes n'achète
plus bio ils achètent local que ce soit
Île-de-France ou ailleurs c'est quand
même intéressant pour une femme comme
elle qui est présidente de région et là
elle a une belle rhétorique de la partie
qui vaut pour le tout de la région qui
vaut pour la France il faut regarder ça
plutôt que les Français et puis Edouard
Philippe il veut prendre la posture de
l'homme rationnel qui n'est pas dans
l'émotion il a pas pris d'ailleurs la
parole sur Annecy je crois pas mais il
faut regarder des sondages moins connu
j'en prends un qui je trouve passionnant
un scindage demandé par le CNRS lui
Français sur 10 attendent d'avoir plus
d'informations scientifiques et c'est
corroborés par le succès des youtubeurs
sur les voilà non ce que je veux dire
par la Myriam c'est que c'est un scoop
d'ailleurs les Français et bien ils
existent en vrai très bien vous avez un
peu abusé de l'expression oui bien sûr
parce qu'on cherche à s'adresser d'une
manière ou d'une autre et très directe
avec nos compatriotes le général de
Gaulle ne parlait pas les Français il en
parlait beaucoup il parlait de la France
c'est vrai notre conception de voir les
choses il faut faire appel en permanence
à l'intelligence de nos compatriotes
Michel Rocard disait les Françaises au
nom d'intelligence
confondantes c'est un peuple très mûr
très politique très informé et donc il
faut se méfier des emballements des
sondages il faut aller au fond
examiner leur pensée leur cœur pour pour
mieux comprendre que secondes peuple
veut et avec sincérité et vérité et on
en trouve de la vérité de la sincérité
dans tous ces dans tous ces destins le
courage guider leur pas 12 destins face
à l'Histoire c'est donc à lire chez
Talandier merci beaucoup Manuel Valls de
nous avoir accompagnés dans cette
émission Les Affranchis à vendredi
prochain Elsa à la semaine prochaine
c'est le weekend profitez bien à très
vite
[Musique]